there are more of you than them
there just aren't enough of you in one
place talking about people who value
family I'm talking about people who
value the First Amendment I'm talking
about people who value the Second
Amendment I'm talking about people who
still think this is the greatest country
on Earth and we are going down the wrong
path YouTube go ahead remove us we are
here to lead a mass Exodus off your
platform
now for the first time there's a
potential major competitor
and mug Club you are the proof of
product that it can work
so all that needs to happen is there
needs to be a platform that allows
people to speak freely
that's the vision for the state of New
Media that's the vision of Rumble and
that's the vision in which we you mug
Club are the tip of the spear
[Applause]